do you know how many times I [__]
pound I worked in a [__] liquor store
at 34 cuz all these [__] 27 year olds
are like why am I not a [__]
trillionaire I'm like cuz you're [__]
27 right and to play this [__] game
the amount of people do the amount of
people who come through Bar store email
come through uh call in and they say
like I've got what it takes I want to do
it I'm going to work so hard at it I
want to be like you and we're like cool
do it write a Blog start a podcast they
don't they give up in a [__] 2 days
dude like two days I'm like do this for
uh 4 years straight with no feedback no
money no nothing and then we can start
talking I want to be famous I want to
live a 1% life I'm like eat [__] for a
decade and they're like what I'm like
you want to live attention is the number
one
asset vayer Nation how are you I'm
really excited this is pretty important
I have three incredible friends with me
this is actually where I'm thinking
about going with my podcast uh obviously
a lot of you know that listen a lot of
my podcast is chopped up from the stuff
we're filming from talks or me moving
because I'm busy and I'm not really
allocating time to create on the flip
side there's a part of me as I head into
2024 that really misses creating because
you're of the moment you're of the SE
the stuff you do I mean you're on
[__] Instagram in one second after
something happens in sports and you got
your take and there's a lot going on
with my be friends thing for the people
watching on Twitch right now big shout
out I'm actually going to use this to
build up twitch as well and start uh
being live on Twitch when I do my
podcast and we're going to call podcast
with friends and what we're going to do
is me and my crew Tyler Zack Dio a lot
of us Sam she's always out there like a
lot of us are always just watching and
cheering for the people that we're going
to have on the show so we've done this
in the past I've done podcast uh with
two or three or four people at the same
time mix from different places but I
have even more clarity on why I like it
uh I was giving a keynote at vcon vcon
August 8th to the 11 2024 go to von.com
to check it out it's going to be in La
this year everybody needs to come
through but um I said something there
off the cuff that said my real passion
is that strangers become acquaintances
acquaintances become friends and then
friends become family MH and it's kind
of what I'm thinking about with this
podcast what we're going to be doing
going forward a lot more often maybe
even once or twice a week because I'm
going to do an original podcast live
fresh of the topics like the Jets lost
to the Raiders they're about to play the
the do excuse me the bills up in Buffalo
like this will air before that like like
in that week fresh and more importantly
I'm hoping that for you the audience a
lot of these people will go from being a
stranger to an acquaintance for some of
you that have seen them oh you've seen
them but now you're more into
acquaintance to friend for some of you
that are hardcore fans of these people
the way we all chop up in this unique
format may lead from friends to family
like you like them more and then for the
three individuals MH that join me I'm
just hoping that they connect with their
people and something happens
and so we're here episode one of uh
podcast with friends and we're going to
introduce these friends to you vayer
Nation we're going to start here ladies
first always to the left please tell
everybody who you are what you do then
we're all going to just chop it up and
then all of you are going to ask me a
question at the end for a Q&A session
please please be already selfish about
that because I want it to be good for
your career or your life or whatever the
[__] you care about let's rock and roll
okay well I like the ladies first um my
name is law since for ladies always win
so ladies first and ladies always win um
I'm a singer a songwriter so I create
music I have a podcast I am an
influencer um I really like to think of
myself as a communicator and I kind of
just have different platforms and ways
that I communicate yeah my messages but
music is definitely my greatest gift and
my loudest communication right now so
that's kind of what I do and where did
you grow up I grew up in Upstate New
York so in Kingston love it born and
raised born and raised well I was born
like 20 minutes around there but I was
there like all of you know first grade
through 12 and you always wanted to sing
um where I get later no I I always
wanted to be a singer from like a I
started playing piano when I was four
okay um and like literally literally
this blonde hair I saw Hanah Montana yes
and like literally the episode where she
was like jumping on the bed with the r
White Guitar which I literally W from
Six Flags and you're like I was like I
want to do that and then like yeah I
kind of was just like I always knew I
would to high school and I got into
fights with my guidance counselor every
week cuz she was like you know SATs and
you got to go to college and I was like
I'm going to be a pop star and you know
that wasn't and here we are but here we
are right and now I'm sitting talking to
Gary ve czy it works my man Kevin Clancy
people call me KFC or KFC bar stool um I
started bar stool in New York the New
York branch of of everything at bar
stool in'
09 uh where we were just blogging at the
time we were just writing all day long
10 or 15 posts a day uh uh and then I
jumped on the podcast wave I knew that
was going to be uh the next big thing
for Barcelo so I've been doing my
podcast there for since
2012 uh and then you know video after
that which is my video series on social
media called one minute man so we kind
of do all of it you're proud of that one
minute man [__] yeah man love it love it
what do you think about that uh that
brand positioning I don't I don't even
know what that is I'm be honest well you
know what a one minute man is in real
life right like no someone who lasts one
minute like
like
s oh my God that was like what is like a
for that this is like me all the time
though people say things and I'll be
like no focused on task at hand not your
dirty head
going there we go yeah um and so now I
mean I've been there yeah what's that
almost like 15 years 14 years whatever
so and now it's an iconic brand versus
crazy dud when you're a grandpa you're
going to be talking about it and they're
going to know what it is versus even
when we met you guys were still in the
come up totally I mean I and I never
ever thought it was going to be like
this I was happy I just wanted to get a
job that was not a job like I just
wanted to talk sports or shoot the [__]
or something and I was one of the Bronx
New York guy like through and through
right so like Mike and the Mad Dog like
dog yeah Mike and dog were like my thing
you know Boomer and carton all those
guys um I went to forom and that has I
believe the best radio and
Communications program
in the country Syracuse some people say
I think it's for lot people from my high
school went to went to forom yeah and if
you're if you're which one's considered
more bougie and which one's considered
more Street what between what forom and
Syracuse um I don't know the answer to
that are both Bouie com schools probably
I think I mean it's a you know consider
good com school but I think you know
from forom that I like I know so many
people from for there's a lot I mean if
you look at sports media it's you know
mikeen I
Eagles though yes yeah yeah that's for
sure that's not even close Sports
uh the Nerds are over here the guys who
play it you know no C got both yeah well
okay uh but I would say for being
totally but I think I mean when you're
at forom you get to cover the Mets the
Jets are would you fight a forom sports
cter in a fight to settle this like can
I put on Syracuse broadcast Syracuse can
I get you at ause podcaster sports
personality to fight to settle this very
challenging thing that we've all been
trying to figure out which is who's got
a better broadcast school or
syc we have the program for that twitch
big shout out to all of you get ready
it's coming we're going to use this
build up twitch this podcast thank you
for being here Johnny V what's good
aquab boms what's good stunt tuck nft
what's good Studio Steve what's
good so no you're not into no but you
know what we we have at Barcelo we have
Ruff and rowdy
I've said ER I've said this to Da I've
said this to you I think maybe even on
the podcast when I was on with you a
couple years ago forever I will say this
Ruff and Rowdy was the seed of what's
Happening Now 100% the Paul brother
celebr boxing R and Rowdy now one could
argue Kimbo Slice and that was the seed
before Ruff and Ruff and Rowdy was a
[__] pay-per-view y I have I have I
give a nor I think this is lost in
history MH I mean this yeah I think
certain things get lost in history y
sometimes when you're the first you're a
little too early things so fast nowaday
but but you know what sometimes you want
to talk about like people know I was an
early investor on Facebook and Twitter I
don't talk enough about that I started a
YouTube show eight weeks after YouTube
launched eight weeks after YouTube
launched yeah like that's not on my
resume that all of you walk around
knowing like yo Gary B was like early
actual real YouTuber wow I let that get
lost in history I'm trying to recoup it
right now YouTube now Tope anyway
brother I'm glad you're
on especially I want to talk a little
bit Michael Carter got cut who I love
with all my heart but lot going on in
our Jets all right my man uh Dale Moss
former NFL wide receiver um I a lot of
people know did you say Randy Moss uh I
wish that was a compar comparison often
uh former NFL wide receiver transitioned
out of sports uh now sports and
entertainment host uh a lot of people
know me from the reality World um but uh
since you know my my main focus now is
filmm
um I'm currently producing uh developing
three docu series working with Radical
Media Academy Award win production
company um and doing a lot of things you
know as a Creator um again covering NFL
games uh Sports is is near and dear to
my heart but uh storytelling um is a
passion of mine and I think put together
right yeah 100% And I I I feel like for
so long in my life I was so afraid to
share my own story um that I grab so I I
grew up in South Dakota uh small town
Midwest uh so you needed to be humble
right you didn't do that kind of [__] or
was it something else no it was I I
think so my mom's side dis owner because
of biracial marriage um very isolated
Community Sports was my Pathway to break
through so many barriers safe place um
but you know my family structure was was
very strong my dad suffered pretty
heavily from uh heroin addictions uh you
know was in and out of prison till the
time I was 21 um but even with all those
things that occurred like our like we
were raised right you know our our love
and uh support from our family was
unconditional but I know that like
everything I did as I was growing up I
was so everyone judged me right or they
were just waiting for something to
happen because at that point if I [__]
up they your mom's side of the family I
think just the community I was in right
which was the broader version of your
mom's side of the family makes sense you
know so again South Dakota you know only
black kid in my school for uh till the
time I was in high school but I had this
fear of if I made a mistake everything
everyone ever thought about my family or
myself would then be true it would be
true God damn that's a big burden to
carry and you know what it's funny like
this is like what's so interesting about
life like what I'm excited about to get
into these episodes and I appreciate you
going there right off the bat like we
all have that like this concept of
judgment is something I'm spending a lot
of time thinking about like y know my
content like I'm trying to get people to
understand what's actually going on like
judgment's a killer MH like like think
about and by the way listening to his
story we all know kids go extreme one
way or the other on that you either like
I'm never going to make a [__]
mistake to show y'all or I'm like or you
go [__] it it doesn't matter no matter
what I do you're always going to judge
me so [__] it I'm just going to make
mistakes yeah ex there's only one answer
to that they're on two sides of the
pillow but they're going to be [__]
extreme
and uh but I I will say you know as as
time went on like uh you learned to let
go of those things but I'm I'm grateful
for how I how I grew up how I was raised
um and it's allowed me do you think your
adversities are your foundation 100%
yeah um I remember there one time uh
again I came you know a lot of people
know me from the reality world yeah tell
everybody about that cuz there going be
a lot of people you mentioned it just
again there's going to be so many people
that listen to this show over next year
or two like a lot of them won't know who
you are from that also break down go
ahead yeah so I was on uh I was on The
Bachelorette in 2020 uh during the
pandemic so right so that small show
yeah so pretty sure most watched reality
show in the history of Television um
also I had a very unique experience
because uh you know on my season the
lead at the time decided to uh stop the
show and we ended up Le leaving together
early um which uh you know I I never
it's like reality TV Hall of Fame
material yeah like I even know what
you're talking about yeah it never not
in full detail but I'm like yep I
remember that [__] you know cuz I'm like
work every second about a season of The
Bachelor ending that way I don't really
this is ironic but you can see it look
at the face I was say if I had a chance
to stop the show and just take this
[__] home I would too
[__] I'm stopping this podcast
right now see everyone have a great time
look like that um but you know that that
goes back to like wanting to do things
right right I had this naive belief uh
that you could make it work with anybody
and I think sometimes when you have that
approach uh just because of what my mom
and my sisters had to go through I
wanted to be that so badly for someone
else and solve the problems super hero
exactly a lot a lot of that [__] in me
too but but you can lose yourself in
that but I will say that's the greatest
experience I ever had um you know I grew
a lot from it I went through some [__]
in the media but I never comprom
compromised my character and integrity
it taught you about yourself for you too
you're still young the world can love
you how old are you uh 35 yeah you're
young dude this is a couple years ago
right three now D so like you learn a
lot about yourself mhm yeah and you can
be the world can love you and something
happens and then it changes overnight
but um I think anytime you go through
something like that especially with
millions of people kind of watching
every move um and and you can maintain
your integrity and who you are and that
Lose Yourself let's actually go around
here a little bit with like back to like
what I want to do with this there's
probably going to be this is so fun cuz
I like to like improv and innovate in
real time on the show so of like you
even see what's what I have on the table
with be friends like I was like you know
what this will work for me because I'm
on this journey of building my Pokemon
Marvel Sesame Street called V friends I
got the panda thank you I got the
bulldog and someone else I think the cow
the cow it's common sense I made the cow
common sense cuz I believe it's really
underrated and I know and I know that
cows are popular so like there's like I
love cows this is why I'm doing this
every day on my story I post a cow it's
like my dream to have like a need get
set cow swag let's do that so now no one
can judge me open to see if you pull if
this was a cow I'm going to think that
this was Max major and I'm G to freak
out I'm going to literally scream and
all these winners are going to break now
I'm scared oh actually I'm going to go
around the horn right now and ask
actually let's see what you pulled let's
see okay we have is this a bass fish no
that you can read it it's at the top I
think it's a brilliant barracuda
barracuda okay the woke walrus I to that
I Just wallus Energy Karma kiwi I'm big
on Karma oh my gosh she's cute okay
um persistent penguin that's me that's
you right there it's a rookie card too
wasn't in series one all right doing a
little nerdy stuff like that okay real
quick Around the Horn now that we're
talking about this I'm going to do this
on every episode team keep me honest on
this one or two words that you think
most describe you who you are as you sit
with me
today Jesus yes law Gary I've never been
a therapy so that's a deep bass question
yeah honestly live Stu yeah like just
like like honestly real talk like and by
the way like you know sometimes people
can answer like you know right away and
you know I'm I'm saving you I'm G doing
this right now to give you a little time
but like they have a little time not me
I'm right next first you know you know
what word or two do you think most
describe you right
now um I was actually thinking about
getting this tattooed so that's deep
yeah so this really resonates with you
yeah um I would say resilient I've like
learned that that's like my superow is
that like every time I'm going through
something super hard I'm like kind of
just like ah like I I don't give up very
easily and I kind of like would so again
like whatever like I'm just like good at
dealing with [__] I guess but then I
realized like wow like I just don't stop
and like that's kind of why I've been
able to get where going resilience a lot
it's funny with be friends one of the
things I'm trying to do is change the
narrative on things so the mascot of my
entire IP the Mickey Mouse the Pikachu
is the very very very very lucky black
cat yeah hell yeah hell yeah and so
resilience is something I really admire
and it's funny I don't like that like
not that I like the devil don't worry
everybody but like I'm trying to do some
contradictions so in V friends world the
resilient is the resilient Red Devil and
like I'm trying just trying to change
some conversations dig a little bit
deeper I love resilience I love that my
man where you at right now uh I'm I'm in
the same place I'm always in I I
uh I'm always trying to be what's next
you know like uh Innovative I guess so
curious yeah I mean like we I was
adaptive I was blogging when that was
new I started the podcast I know I I
know your career well I'm a fan adaptive
Innovative curious all probably all uh I
I I I hesitate to use the word
Trailblazer because I think it's
dramatic but what I have always of you
to say that right now yeah don't do that
but I but I what I do it in the sense of
like iconic
no legendary the
best the single greatest human that ever
worked on Earth I think I do it in a
literal way though like I will I have
always done it first and then someone at
the company or someone else has taken it
Fearless to the next level and I'm kind
of happy with that like I'm yeah all
right [__] it Fearless I guess I think
all these things are a little bit
dramatic when we're talking about you
know social media accounts and content
and whatnot but why like we like like
honestly like if you think about I don't
think anybody should be afraid there's
no Fe you know like good brother I have
good news for you the entire world's
afraid yeah yeah yeah that's that's bro
the only yeah the only thing that's
happening right now is fear yeah like do
you know what this podcast is about for
me personally building blocks to
eliminate fear MH friendship is how you
eliminate fear back to interracial
marriages what's going on in the Middle
East right now like the only way things
happen good is if people become friends
y especially when they don't look like
each other yeah yeah yeah yeah
everyone's yeah no I get that I get that
I just I just didn't want to be dramatic
about it but I do think we're just
talking about to your point we're just
talking about content but guess what
like what sports do you you know this
you just like a lot of us are let's use
this as a theme athletes used to not get
paid a lot of money in 1930 4050 you
know much more famous a pilot was in
America yeah outside of Mickey Mantle
like like the 1982 NBA Finals was on
tape delay right that's crazy it wasn't
aired live cuz it was that not
popular like magic and bird where they
really became like yeah so like so like
like I don't know like content like like
did you hear what law said she watched
Hannah Montana she watched her that ass
love you Miley if you're watching this
watch Miley being a Nickelodeon show and
it changed her life like we may say like
listen every time we make a piece of
content this included I'm hoping one of
the four of us says something for not
PCX on Twitch or Juan G or or blessed
downstairs or the millions that will
listen over the next 3 years of this
podcast I'm hoping we say one thing
right and by the way entertainment which
is what you do that's escapism yeah what
is movies and music and sports it's
letting us deal with the [__]
hardships of the world like everything
is I could be super stressed and I have
a lot going on in my life but at Sunday
at 4:25 p.m. this Sunday I don't care
about anything but but beat the [__]
Buffalo Bills they've been struggling
you know what I
mean what do you think uh I would say I
would say complete and curious um
complete and curious complete do you
feel do you feel complete I feel the
most complete in my life that I have I
know that I'm not let me ask you a
different I yes I love that what about
content because I'm curious how you
Define complete versus content cuz I see
people think content bad and I think
content greatest state of humanity yeah
when you're content but hungry like
that's how I feel that's why I jumped on
that yeah I mean I'm good at all moments
I've been good cuz I also got raised
right before I even started which is why
I think everything's happening I don't
need another good thing to happen you're
set yeah I'm good but I want to [__]
tear it all down oh I yeah slave for
sure so I I would say like content to me
um is complacent a little bit yeah this
is why I'm fascinated by this word this
why this is why I'm playing with this
right now because line is like I'm
grateful I feel like I can make the best
of any situation but I feel like for so
long in my life I was doing things
probably for other people now I said
[__] it I'm doing things for myself
building things but I'm also curious in
trying new things like like it you know
I'm in the gaming space I'm doing twitch
I'm trying and these are things I never
would have done for short I'm not trying
to change his word I actually re Liz for
Schwarz said Gary out here trying to
change his word I'm not actually I'm
like so fascinated by his word and some
sometimes in my excitement of
Fascination I'll jump in and I get why
you felt that and I understand that no
it's actually I'm like so impressed by
that word and I'm also fascinated by
content and then he followed it up with
the word that I think we're both
foundationally grounded in which is
gratitude when you're actually grateful
it's a rap yeah like it's a rap it's why
gratitude gorilla like like and by the
way what's what I'm setting up here is
what I've been trying to figure out like
listening to y'all my big thing with be
friends when I start doing animation and
books and like build this out is it's
actually never one thing mhm it's
gratitude and curiosity like I think
people are trying to solve things with
one thing yeah when I'm looking at right
these are ingredients this is why V
friends the way they're going to solve
[__] is more like I need three of them
to save the day sure gratitude gorilla
and curious crane need to go to him and
be like no you got this and I don't
think anyone in Earth is talking about
gratitude and curiosity together in an
intense way to solve the the anxiety and
unhappiness and worry that everyone's
laying at home with yeah and I think
we're trying to solve with one trait
when it's a mix of three sure yeah no I
agree I agree and I just being curious I
feel secure to a point now where I can
go and if I make a mistake or something
doesn't you know it flops it's like all
right [__] it like I'm good like that I
feel worth TR when you get beyond that
point I feel like that is a very
critical point of almost any
like cuz there to go back to that fear
thing there are so many people afraid to
do something and it doesn't blow up and
you're not famous right away and you
don't get the views but I I I hadit A
Moment Like a couple years ago that was
very it was it was the very corny like
there's no such thing as failure it was
just like learning along like one minute
man we started in
2017 and it worked and it was doing well
and then Facebook changed their
algorithm the views plummeted it kind of
fell off and I was like all right like I
failed that sucks and then the pandemic
hits Instagram's doing some [__] with
their uh user generated content and all
of a sudden it comes you know back and
it was like our our guys's emailed being
like we need short form video that's
topical and I was like I can do this
I've already done this and what I
thought it was a failure I like slid it
back in and then this this time it grows
and I was like oh wow that was not in
the moment I thought it was a failure
and then 3 four 5 years later I realized
oh no no it was just wasn't the right
time was the right situation and now it
is so then I was like how many other
things am I right now failing at that
I'm like oh I got to wait till I'm you
know 40 42 46 40 and then those things
become let's talk about
that this the world and I'd love to get
all three of your perspective the world
is so absolute even think about this
conversation winning failing working not
working going back to a little bit what
you touched on brother like for me and
I'm curious L you know you're so early
in your career like things are starting
to happen for you like like you know
knowing your ambition if if Hannah
Montana is that nordstar like you're
trying to be as famous as you possibly
can yeah right and then and so I think
about like a couple things that I'd love
to get your all three of your reactions
to my big thing is like even the
Frameworks of winning and losing like
it's why I love process like my great
dream is that the world finds success
yeah so like to me the reason that was
really interesting for me KFC is that to
me if I'm just doing what I want to be
doing is I of of course I want it to do
well MH sure but I'm just like secretly
and this is maybe the Jets fandom in me
real talk secretly and I'm curious CU
you now all three of you have had all
three of you have had more wins in the
way the world defines it than than the 8
billion people on average of 8 billion
people on earth right yep so I'm
actually really curious where where you
going to all three can to take this for
me if people fall in love with the
process like actually MH and I don't
know I feel like I'm in some weird next
level of this video game where I almost
like like when it's not working more
yeah the grind yeah a new version [__]
me up because like now I've gotten to a
place that I don't like as much as I did
10 years ago where people actually like
do think it's GNA work yeah like
secretly I like where be friends is
right now yeah because I don't think
people like really like I can't wait for
like I'm enjoying I want to be
underrated at all times and the more
success you pile on it gets harder be
underated when I was in my dad's liquor
store at
32 at 32 and my friends from high school
and college came to buy wine and liquor
and I would ring them up at the register
and bring the case of wine to their BMW
cuz they worked in Street and they would
drive off and I was the working in my
dad's store at how old are you 38
beautiful like 35 38 ladies we don't
have but you know but like but like I
just want you to hear this at 34 years
old I worked in a liquor store yeah
that's crazy and people walking in and
like I saw what they looked at I know
what judgment looks like yeah yeah facts
yeah well you also had a bit glow up to
it's easy to pick it up yeah but but but
but you know what when you have the glow
up in your head that you've already been
glow
right because you're just in your Zone
regardless if you get to the place you
got to or not like I wish people knew
how happy I was then in that moment I
feel like people can feel that though
like if you you know like how you care
yourself and what you exude though like
that it it shines through for sure but
maybe they were just too blind to see it
or they're focused on so many different
things well they also their definition
is different than your definition that
you know this is the whole point can we
like to me Law Won and I don't believe I
mean it law and I don't think always win
and I don't we're getting the the brand
we're getting the point here we're
getting the point I learned this I'm I'm
going agree no but listen this is real
talk
like but winning is not an event though
I feel like that's kind of what I like
that's why I put it in my brand is that
I don't think winning is like at the end
of a day or at the end of like a game
like you won this or you lost this
winning is like a lifestyle and it's
just something that like you do in your
day to day I feel like it's but can you
live it yeah because it's it's not so
here here's the question professionally
are like what what today actually paint
a picture for the audience because I
want to get to know where do you think
you are in your career like like to the
way we all Define it like I'm on the
come up I got a cosign from this I I had
a flop I'm a I have a song coming out
tomorrow that's gonna like where are you
in your career for all the audience sir
sir I'mma be real with ma yes ma'am I
thought I was at a certain point and I
feel like I think I'm at of a point
right now where people like know who I
am um you know I had a pretty viral
moment right tell everybody cuz I'm
telling you this is the big thing like
all of you got things but like my
audience comes from so like there's a
lot of different and I want them to hear
it and this is for y'all so what was
your viral moment um my first I had a
couple viral moments so I first went
viral in
2021 um for doing loyalty test the most
random thing on earth my friend's
boyfriend or yeah my friend's boyfriend
was cheating on her I made a Tik Tok it
went viral um I became very known for
doing this but obviously I was doing
music so then um when I did that I had a
first song that came out my first song
ever that came out it started doing well
um I made a different Tik Tok account
that was strictly for music and then I
posted my song y me it has like five
million streams so everybody's like you
know whatever it's having its moment um
that's real MH yeah so I think I kind of
like lost where I was going with it uh
where you are oh yeah so I think people
know they know who I am I think that I
would go like live on Tik Tok and people
would be like oh you're the girl that
made that y me song and I was like oh so
like there's people who know the song
who don't know of me um but then I was
at Shop Right yesterday and then Rich
had texted me and was like Hey like are
you like mad casual he was just like
like hey are you like free tomorrow I
think that you're going to be like on
like the Gary ve podcast and I was like
I feel like you're asking me this a
little bit too casual for this super so
and then like once I got the G the whole
night I was thinking you know I feel as
though I'm like I'm like cool right
people know me but I'm not like these
people right I was like looking at all
you guys and I'm like how how did I get
here like how am I sitting at this table
with these people that are like so much
more qualified than me and like so much
more this so I don't know where I'm at I
don't this kind of [__] me up cuz I'm
like I could maybe I'm in a different I
don't know how people view me at this
point I'm just I'm at a I'm not I'm at a
place where I want to keep going so I
don't even like a word like qualified
now I don't even know what the [__] that
means anymore like it use like certain
industries and jobs like a lawyer a
doctor you had to like literally get a
qualification brcas need to go to
[__] forom or Syracuse to crush man I
I got I got my
NBA out the [__] window you know like
do like what's your title like now
everybody's a everyone's a renaissance
man and woman I love but also it can be
like I I'm 18 years old and I made the
right video and I popped off and that's
how I have my fans or I'm 50 and I
grinded for 25 years and then I had my
moment but it's like I don't know if you
can fill a room selling tickets or get
your stream on your your music or you
know get uh people to watch your film
whatever it is it's like then that's I'm
qualified you know what I mean there's
no there's no well here's why the
internet decentralized
everything used to be systems now
qualifies the world let me give you a
little history lesson on my business
career when I started doing public
speaking and was cursing and not wearing
a suit everyone told me you'll never be
a big speaker right right and I was like
I'm not capable of doing
anything by the way real and real talk
it wasn't like [__] you it was
definitely confidence yeah I was like I
don't think so but it was like if I
don't that's okay cuz I don't even like
talking that way like I won't I won't
like this goes back to process
redefining success I wasn't going to
Define My Success based on my speaking
fee or how many people went to my talks
I was going to Define it based on not
not even selling out I didn't view it as
selling out I didn't view me wearing a
suit and not cursing as selling out it
wasn't that cool MH it was I'm not
capable of enjoying it yeah right this
huh this is my report card right okay
I'm not a dummy I'm not in oh it's your
Lal report C it's my little you got an F
in German twice why [__] take a
German in the first place I thought it
was close to Russian I [__]
up I went to high school they're like
what language like German's probably
close to Russian I'll crush it f
freshman year F sophomore year look at
Junior year I had to take Spanish one
I'm a junior in Spanish one fourth
graders in there I'm like what's good
this was awful what junior year I [__]
up heavy it's oh how did you pass they
just pushed my ass through look at my
class R they want to see you anymore
tell them my class rank
243 out of out of it's right there right
next to it please don't say 250
254 well
look what I got tell them what I got in
speech back to how school doesn't map
real life in speech class giving
speeches where the hell is think it was
sophomore year maybe 10th grade I got a
f in Reading I guess oh speech d d is
meanwhile bro I got a D in speech
everybody got an A in that class all you
had to do was write a speech go in front
of the class and give the speech and you
got an A
got got an A no no all four years by the
way that's all four years please tell
them the only A's I got in high school
start with ninth grade KFC nth grade you
got an A in fizzed uh 10th grade 10th
grade you got an A in fed there it is
these are the only A's I got 11 grade
only a fed and Senor here no you got two
you got two uh health class health I was
what they called a Gym Class
Hero I wasn't good enough I music guys
if if if High School was actual Sports
I'm a first ballot what's your favorite
gym class game ever floor hockey I used
to kill [__] used
Tove [__] out of those uh curve the [__]
out of the stick to the point that it
was like a hook and you it was like high
was that
frustration nobody in the history of Jim
tried harder than did you play mat did
you do matball
yeah is either like
a a regional thing though lot of people
don't even know map ball just kest but
it's like you got to run around twice
and you're playing dodgeball kind of we
played pickle ball in high school pickle
Ball's having this big moment now when I
was in high school my gym my gym
teachers we had rankings on the wall gym
teachers were playing kidle was mushroom
they were mushroom all right let's get
back track let's get back to track let's
go back to track here we go ready to
help the audience you guys are running
in circles of people that are trying to
achieve in different genres let's talk
about persp we've talked a little bit
about ourselves let talk about persp
Ives if I asked you cuz I want to help a
lot of the kids that are listening and
really the parents that are these
everybody is now going to be famous to
15 people like the world's changed every
15y old is trying to be on this podcast
you know what I mean like it's over the
cat's out of the bag nobody's behind the
scenes even my dck was not like people
nobody's [__] behind the scenes
Dustin's [__] super cool all right
here we
go for everybody who's listening for
everybody who's listen Dustin's cool for
everyone's
listen what is the common when you this
is going to really be fun we'll go in
reverse order I'll give you a little
time to think thanks Gary reality TV
sports Hollywood now land you've been
playing in a bunch of lands in your
young life yeah what's the what's the
cliche very common mistake you see of
the your contemporaries the people you
look up to the people that are on the
come up the people that are in the
trenches with you at these parties at
these meetings at these events what's
the cliche a mistake that you think that
your contemporar friends acquaintances
are making that's leading them to not be
as happy as they can be I feel like I
feel like they're doing what everyone
else is doing or just trying to school
right meaning like if because everyone's
doing this or it's like this is or
they're looking for the
answers um I I was actually thinking
about this the other day um because you
know I've I've especially in the last
few years especially since uh reality
television I I really pivoted because I
didn't want to be in a box that everyone
else in that world is and um I kind of
went against the grain but I I feel like
it's safe to be with a crowd and I feel
like we gravitate towards that because
you know we want to have people around
us but is it that we want people around
us or is that we don't want to stand out
to be different to deal with the
ramifications of not being or more
importantly the ramifications of being
seen yeah I think people are afraid to
be seen judged you know and when you're
out there um again I say like the
greatest thing for me that happened is I
was I was judged my whole life and once
I finally got it was easier for you you
were built for by the time you went into
reality TV World between sports and
between being only black kid in South
Dakota School your whole life you were
used to being judged yeah I'm like I
this was an experience but I was like
that's not I'm not cut from that cloth
that's not my world um but now I'm
building um everything I've ever wanted
to um and I'm doing this I like without
it as as much guidance as you would
think but I am certain that I'm going to
get there and I've got amazing people
around me who I trust like through the
moon um and you know they're they're
leaders in the industry so I do you feel
like back to being complete back to the
conversation we're having do you feel
like even if everything you try to make
in film storytelling shows does not have
Commercial Success that you'll that
you'll deem it a win or you're not
completely sure I I without question
it's a win yeah you're in the process I
love it I'm I'm going to skip for a
second I apologize but like
I [__] want that for everyone it
makes me so happy for you you can't
imagine yeah this is the exact your
world you've been in the modern media
world at the highest levels y so there's
been all the other things that have come
up that have looked apart of y'all and
different genres you've been in a lot of
events like what are you seeing I think
it's almost there's no correct answer
but I would say there's no correct there
almost is man in the sense of comparison
dude comparison it comparison is the
thief of joy is the line right
to me I I watched it I did it myself cuz
it was
like I got to make my blog this good and
I did that and then I added a podcast
and I got to make my podcast that good
and then I got to make my video series
that good and every time I like if you
would if you were to tell me five years
ago you were gonna have your podcast was
going to be the successful I would be
like oh I would have I would be putting
my feet up being like I'm done I I did
it like I'm I'm that successful that's
all I ever wanted and it's like that
that goal in a in a good way it's good
to be driven but also it's like you're
just constantly comparing to who's next
and what's next and the amount of people
I think especially you know at bar it's
like you're you're next to uh Dave
pornoy pardon my take Alex Cooper people
who are like you can't you can't reach
their level if you were to [__] hit
the lottery tomorrow you know what I
mean it's like so you or you might you
might but but I'm saying but sit there
comparing yourself to them is not going
to get you anywhere and why didn't you
compare yourself to them long before
they were them
this is what I'm trying to tell all my
friends they like [__] you want to
compare why don't you compare yourself
do you know I mean I did it already in
this show do you know how many times I
[__] pound I worked in a [__]
liquor store at 34 cuz all these [__]
27 year olds are like why am I not a
[__] trillionaire I'm like cuz you're
[__] 27 right or ands to play this
[__] game the amount of people dude
the amount of people who come through
bar stol email come through uh call in
and they say like I've got what it takes
I want to do it I'm going to work so
hard at it I want to be like you and
we're like cool do it write a Blog start
a podcast they don't they give up in a
[__] two days dude like two I'm like
do this for uh four years straight with
no feedback no money no nothing and then
we can start talking I want to be famous
I want to live a 1% life I'm like eat
[__] for a decade and they're like what
I'm like you want to live 1% life you
have to like it like when I I'm trying
to help people now at parsal more like
produce and it's like if it doesn't make
money right away get followers right
away get views right away like when I
was starting the podcast I never looked
at I still don't look at the downloads I
never looked at the page views I never
looked at it was just cuz I liked doing
real quick we're going to interject for
a second big shout out to MJS 3169 who
says that crooked picture frame is
making me lose my
mind oh the Uber what is that oh Read
that read that read it KFC read what
that frame says I want to say thank Uber
the microphone here we
go uh this is from James at Uber hey AJ
I wanted to say thank you for being our
first ever Uber Rider in New York how
was your exp one more time let's start
up from the top James at Uber to AJ
marock hey AJ I wanted to say thanks for
being our first ever Uber driver in New
York how was your experience period
let's stop crazy talk about making tons
of mistakes in one in a career Travis
CEO of ubber in my office in New York
early days of Vayner we're early
investors in Uber he's like hey we're
about to open New York do you want to go
downstairs and do the first test run I'm
like I'm busy I'm in this meeting I said
AJ do me a favor go take this Uber so i
s my brother ever do you guys understand
how often I would tell this [__]
story a my brother AJ took the first
Uber in I mean York City do you know
[__] fun fact that is do you know
when you like have a meeting or
something people like hey what's a fun
fact you're like yeah I took the first
Super in New York what the [__] out of
here that's so epic it was a base Fair
of seven bucks distance was $6 776 what
day what day was that email sent uh
April 8th 2011 wow this goes back to the
theme of everything [__] takes a long
time yeah [__] takes a long time mhm
like I don't understand like you know
what I mean like [__] takes a long time
yeah all right um let's all open a pack
yeah why why did you have me open yeah I
had you do open open a mini these were
in vending machines I just wanted to see
if you liked it remember these things
when you're little like for 50 cents
it's just it's so L he's freaking me out
a little bit I'm not going to lie yeah
the comparison things so real brother
like bro you know I've been saying like
uh I Ed my the the analogy I've been
using is a swimming pool feel like
people want to get a swimming like they
want a swimming pool right this they
think they think for Curious yeah
curious crane hell yeah like trading car
um and then you get your swimming pool
you never [__] swim in your swimming
pool you know what I mean like you you
think I want to buy this house and it's
like get in the pool you wanted the pool
and now you got it you're not swimming
in the pool everybody wants a big house
that they don't use 85% of the room
totally uh and then what you get what's
your favorite one of the bunch um uh hot
[__] Hornet bro I
can't did you come up with all of
these I drew every one of them see that
Jack did you come up with the names
everything created this whole world what
is this alien one in adaptable alien
impeccable
instate Russian for alien got it I was
going to say this is not a real animal I
know that much it's an alien I can't
believe that how many how many like two
there's 280 V friends so I with all of
them yeah yep I I always was I was super
affected by like He-Man Transformers I'm
I'm 48 so I grew up in the 80s when like
all that [__] Care Bears like all that
[__] that rebooted for all of you I was
there when it actually first popped off
you know and so um yeah it's pretty it's
pretty cool and something I've always
really really really wanted to do I
wanted to buy an old brand so like for
the last 15 years I thought I was going
to buy Scooby-Doo or buy The Smurfs buy
the IP and then refurbish it but then
when but then when I saw the blockchain
nft thing I'm like you know what I'm
going to do the [__] myself why don't
you do both cuz I think there's a Smash
Hit there if you bring back listen if I
if I over the next 30 Years build V
friends the way I hope to then I become
like a Disney Disney built and then they
bought yeah Lucas Star War they bought
Marvel so look I'm 48 in 20 years if I
do this proper and I'm 68 and this
Brand's really established building an
IP holding company and going out and
buying you know a Nickelodeon IP or or
Scooby-Doo will be really cool but right
now I've literally so much work to do to
build this up you know but I really
believe in it like if you look at like
back to like kind of the theme of this
and like the theme of my life and why I
built this characters and why this
podcast I think will work is like these
themes of these characters or what we're
talking about it's real life and for me
if I can teach people at 5 six seven8
like accountable ant actually let's talk
about this let me talk about accountable
ant accountable ant is like a character
I'm like really hot on because I think
what's [__] up with the world right
now is lack of accountability it's
everybody else's fault it's the
government's fault it's B's fault it's
tr's fault it's your mom's fault it's
your dad's fault it's this company's
fault it's social media's fault it's
Kanye's fault it's this it's everyone's
[__] fault by so right I'm real
curious what what's your relationship
with accountability be as honest
self-aware humble but but speak your
truth like where do you where do you
think you are on your journey on
accountabil I actually find music
artists incredibly bad at accountability
it's everyone's fault but their music is
the problem and but it's always your
music's the problem the the answer that
I was going to give to the first
question right like that I see people in
music do wrong yes is I think that they
put too much emphasis and they expect
like their success to come through like
someone else so they expect like a
manager right the manager's going to do
it yeah the lab going to do it yeah they
Tik tok's going to put me up yeah they
don't realize like you have's going to
give me a cosign it's his fault for not
[__] with me literally yeah yeah so I
I would say that I I agree with that um
I think accountability oddly for me like
I have like I think that's like a
superpower of mine like when I was a kid
I used to tell on myself so if I did
anything wrong you own [__] yeah like if
I broke something my brother was older
than me he'd be devising a here's a big
one here's a big one for everyone on
Twitch big shout out to everybody denjet
what's good Majestic Colt accountability
but not going too far where you where
you beat yourself up are you hard on
yourself or have you found the balance
of accountability cuz to me it's
completely not accountable everyone's
fault the beauty the middle
accountability and then the place that I
get scared of when people start [__]
on themselves and beating themselves up
and that's not accountability that's
that's not a good relationship with
yourself yeah yeah I I think that I
don't know yeah I just I always took a
lot of accountability when I was growing
up um so I look at situations like if
I'm upset about something or at somebody
else like my kind of framework that I
work through is like what did I do in
this situation like what is my
participation so you feel like you're in
a good place with it yeah yeah I can
really do that I feel like uh to throw
around a buzzword I got that impostor
syndrome big time yeah where I feel like
I'm hyper self-aware to the point that
I'm always you know syndrome is the new
slang for insecurity right okay I just
want to make sure everyone out there has
let's yeah let's nail let's nail that
down once for all we've Cen up this word
it's insecurity
it's
okay level to me of like when I when I'm
doing this some of the very great
opportunities some of the people I've
talked to I'm like I didn't even really
try to do this plan to do this I am
really just a regular ass dude and the
beauty of the world is like that's
people like me get to do that now but I
still I still think we as a society
that's still a relatively new thing you
used to have to be trained or famous or
look a certain way or act a certain way
that first book in the corner there I
wrote in 2009 crush it when I wrote that
and said this was going to happen I got
[__] on right no you got to be somebody
but I knew YouTube and Twitter were
going to be the found makeal people so I
feel like I'm one of those first ones
where I'm like but so I'm constantly
like I I don't know man I don't have the
answers I don't know the plan I'm just
[__] like regular dude listen first
of all back to like me being a fan of
yours you know what you talk about like
you know your craft of sport I don't
ever yeah I Stay
I know what I know yeah you know what
you know like you're likeable you're
likeable because you have that
relationship with yourself mhm I
actually I don't think people think I'm
likable I I think I I I don't believe
that at all I understand where you're
going because you play sports like
people Chris Russo is incredibly likable
and infuriating and you've got a little
bit of that in you because that's your
not your stick it's your communication
style in that format I love what you
said I'm a communicator me too but I'm a
different Communicator to my best friend
and my I am as Gary I am as Gary Vayner
even the of Gary vaynerchuk for V
friends is a different Communicator than
Gary vaynerchuk the COO of vayer X like
there's different versions of it I think
the the genre you're in yeah is like yes
do I think people likeing but Sports
Talk is polarizing I think it just as
long as you're genuine and real about
human is like yes yes I would agree with
that yeah uh I accountability is
something I don't shy away from if
anything I look forward to it uh do you
think you overextend at times and try to
take it on when it's not even yours uh I
I think I don't beat myself up over it
because if my Integrity is is is right
then if you're good with you then you're
good yeah because I know I make the
right prudent Choice um but I do
probably try to do cover up for other
people's mistakes too many times super
super hero if I can just shout out p p
WB HLN that said nice things about me
regular ass dude who work
hard
I'm shouting
out Ben 1173 KFC not likable I like that
guy all right final part of the show
question time this is your time to go
selfish okay like really I got a lot of
love for you all obviously I know you
all from afar in different ways a little
bit closer with KFC than YouTube but
like you know like we're really excited
here in my world like we're I'm in this
great place where I'm like obsessed with
putting people on I've always been that
guy that's why I've always talked about
the people behind my scenes the first
wine show I did did uh Eric castner and
then Chris Mt mot was my camera guy it
was so basic no lighting no audio no
nothing and I used to be like M link it
up people thought I was saying
ma people like it's so in the
comments it's so cool your mom too
you're like no no M but like dck
obviously I don't have to tell that
story a lot of people know it like I
love putting people on and so I really
hope B Nation please make sure you dig
into all of the obviously in our social
content we'll link all these three
amazing people up get to know them get
on their Journey but back to wrapping it
up in the format I want to do on a show
any question I can answer about any
single thing could be fun it could be
detailed it could be about your career
it could be a funny thing like what do
you
got what are you what are you thinking
about that might be something I might be
able to help with I would say so I I
feel like you were somebody like in you
know life and in you know the Spectre of
people on the internet that I feel like
you did a lot of things that like have
never been done before y um meaning
meaning like you didn't have like an
example you didn't have like that's why
I like him because I think he touched on
touched on it I think he's done similar
stuff I've done a lot of it for a long
time so I I understand it and I
appreciate that I do like that so go
ahead yeah so what would you say like
the most valuable thing that you did in
that journey is and why like that got
you there that you think is valuable not
like the numbers the number one word
that I'm obsessed with that none of you
[__] with is
maybe I just heard something about that
so that's really like just maybe no no
like the word maybe like maybe let will
work out maybe my word in life is maybe
and y'all's word is yes or no
predominantly
Noh like I saw Casey nistad and all
those early vloggers who would do the
camera by themselves I was like I want
to do that [__] but I don't know how to
do that [__] so I'm like maybe I'll have
a guy follow me 247 I wasn't unaware
that everyone was going to immediately
think I'm the douchiest person on human
Earth because unlike a TV production
following a reality star which we
finally accepted 10 years in I was doing
it as like a regular
dude yeah I mean like literally my first
meeting at bar stool with Erica like a
man walked in and was filming she's like
what are you doing I'm like I film
everything she what the [__] are you
talking about I'm like I film everything
film this is how I Vlog but now it is
like standard yeah yeah it's the norm
like even David Rock D rock big shout
out D Rock who's now going on in
building his Universe was with me for a
decade that became the term that people
called people that filmed people I need
a
dck wow like it became that crazy so I'm
always about maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe I should buy a house on Mars maybe
I should like so you just go 100% AI
right now was like oh that shit's going
to [__] us up the robots going to kill
us and [__] that [__] make mus I'm like
no no maybe do because what maybe does
back to curious crane is maybe makes you
work MH the reason people say no is if
you you say no you don't have to do it
now I got you [__] now you
heard no's easy yeah because no allows
you not to do yeah all of you know I
know this one's going to land for all of
you all of you heard me in 2017 18
saying tick tock tick tock tick tock and
all of you said girls that dance nobody
gives a [__] musically musically mus
that's right
I and then all you know so like you know
for me it's maybe and I hope everybody
gets inspired I wish I made a maybe
character I might I'm do think longterm
there will be new fee friends I've got
so many I don't need to do it but Moose
maybe Magpie yeah you know what a magpie
is it's a bird it's [__] fresh we
have a magpie anyway KC question these
are real animals open one more pack open
a pack we
have nobody's open a good one let's get
a rare one you can do two things at once
yeah oh I got a shiny one what do we got
here I got insightful Irish Terrier you
like Irish ters o a hit a rare it's h
out of 500 um I guess I'm at a spot with
bar stool you know it's a very
interesting spot of like it's been a
very tumultuous ride the last year we're
kind of in like a transitional thing
like sold back back this that and it's
like we were gambling but I didn't
gamble now gambling's out of the picture
y uh sometimes I feel like I'm like am I
not I've been there for 15 years almost
15 years right but I'm like and and part
of me the way this is set up right now
is kind of like we could just forever
and you're worried about complacency
kind of like you know should I like be
like I'm going to go do my version of
Port noise thing like thank you take the
equity great time [__] it I'm out why
wouldn't you I don't know it's like
loyalty is it fear big all that loyalty
fear it's easy like the first 15 years
were hard and it's it's a very strange
spot all this [__] to get here I'm going
do it again and it's like and I'm not
very like money driven like I got this
money recently that I was very blessed
to have and like my life has not changed
much one way or the other so I'm like
it's not really about money can I tell
you something really good here I like
this one the answer is and this is a
weird
one it doesn't matter until the day
these feelings hit a Tipping Point in
either direction right and then you know
right it just happens yeah too many
people get caught up in the ideology of
the process versus the actuality of the
process do you know why it was bad at
school cuz it wasn't real to life right
and at 10 years old I'm like this isn't
real now I have no idea how the [__]
that happened no really I mean I really
don't know but I'm telling you real talk
to the you3 and everyone listening I
just knew and I was like if that's true
and I fully believe it not on some I was
getting good grades at that point I was
just like this isn't real yeah and so
like you in your own mind it's actually
not real until it's so in your stomach
that you have to do one or the other MH
yeah so I'll just hit that Breaking
Point rather think about everything
wait for the Tipping Point yeah so it's
just a waiting game and and then watch
this so now instead of stressing it of
what you should do or what am I feeling
or all these profound [__] games we
play with each other how about you just
enjoy the living [__] out of it and if
you just wake up at 6 o'clock in the
morning one day and be like I'm done
then you're done am we need to take
weight off our shoulders bro tell me how
to do it how do you do it the way to do
the way to do it is to start to take the
noise from the world the world is making
everything complicated there's a lot of
great that's happened us Jokers can have
platforms we could be live on Twitch and
hang out with like all these cool people
Ben 1173 you know like you we can do all
this yeah I like Ben because he red you
you know like but like but I think we
just need to simplify right I got good
news for you because it's how it's going
to happen regardless regardless of how
many sleepless nights or debates or
talking with mentors you have MH one day
you're going to wake up and it's there
or one day you won't the reason you're
not gone yet is it hasn't
yet yeah so why not instead of that and
like stressing it why not just enjoy it
swim in the pool and swim in the pool
and then if you [__] want to sell the
house with the pool sell the [__]
house with the pool got it cool my man I
think uh for me the biggest thing right
now uh is kind of patience I'm working
on some big projects that are long
builds uh with the strike with you know
the economy but three big docu series um
and I see them so clearly that like this
is my calling these are going to happen
I I I know that good for you but that
process of just patience especially when
there's so many other things I can't
control and I like to execute quick yeah
it's like you know I just curious like
how you practice patience why why the
question becomes why in a world where
you're so good at managing judgment I
just worry that this is the blind in the
same way that I didn't see that cander
was [__] me up because I always
wanted to keep it positive I wasn't able
to tell people [__] that was [__] up
and that actually led to the [__] up I
didn't see it mhm for you you might not
see the place where judgment does matter
mhm right because for me like why would
you be
impatient I like play here play checkers
with me on this okay it might even be
chess because it's fun okay you got
these longer projects right like I get
instag gratification I get speed of the
world but like if you're so pumped that
this is the thing you're doing and it
sounds like you are yeah like what's the
prob well I guess it's probably more
just anxious because I want this to
happen and I believe in it but and
you're not in control of it happening
somebody has to buy it it's it's Netflix
may not buy it hoola may not buy it
right yeah and we're with q1 Q2 we're
like pitching these but you're but
you're smart enough to know and educated
enough to know that it may not exactly I
the question becomes for you
specifically is do you want it because
it becomes something you can point to
that starts to move you away from
something that you don't want to Define
you I I think
there's I'm not doing it because I don't
want to be defined in that way great
beautiful then then it really just
becomes like what like there's a million
scenarios I'd love it to be commercially
successful so I can get money to do X
yeah I uh I'm so damn curious if I'm
good at it I'd actually like it to come
out to see if it fails or flops just to
win or lose there's a million things
that it could be yeah for me it's I
believe in the stories and I just like I
think they need to be told well then
that gets weird because if you believe
in the stories that they need to be told
you wouldn't be doing it this way
because you don't have as much control
this way than you do in the modern media
world you why don't you just put out
yourself sorry not that I that's exactly
where I'm going well I mean I have full
creative Direction and and control on
these Pro uh these projects you're
putting that format potentially on a
pedestal because if you really care
about these stories need to be told yeah
yeah then there's a very different way
about going about it what what what what
soci and long video like you could do it
constantly at scale until it finally got
told you could literally tell the same
story 8700 different ways on YouTube and
social until it was finally told yeah
yeah and where nobody controls your
distribution yeah but this distribution
has a different level of pedestal yeah
yeah but that's not the purity of
wanting the story told you want the
story told in a specific way well the
what I like these are projects that are
so one's uh we're tracking Special
Olympics athletes build up to the world
games I'm a global Ambassador for the
organization my sister has ID yes um I
just feel people haven't told the
truthful like the the real story but you
don't need to do that in a classic
production lens unless right unless
you're using it as the bank which in
that case you could have went to any
brand at Proctor and Gamble or comcast
to like like these are like the fun
complicated tough questions I always
love to ask myself why why why why you
know y yeah cuz cuz the why has the
answer to the impatience yeah and I'm
going I'm going at it at every single
angle so like all those things there's
there's no no like unturned friends I'm
in thank you it was an honor thank you
for being show this version we've done
something similar to this in the past as
you know but um but uh this is the name
of it this is the concept I hope that
you guys I don't know you're the three
of you you're your relationships with
each other but I hope if you were
strangers that at least this starts your
acquaintances I hope those acquaintances
become friendships and man when friends
become family there's nothing [__]
better on Earth so thanks for listening
everybody twitch thank you for being a
part of this journey you are part of
this journey I've decided to use twitch
exclusively just even though I know I
could stream this everywhere else it's
been a platform that I haven't leaned
fully into so I want to use it exclusive
so for everybody who's listening to this
podcast if you want to catch the podcast
while it's happening in the future that
will always be on Twitch download a set
am I Gary ve on Twitch as well beautiful
I keep it consistent don't you get sick
of it ever never [__] love all like
you want like another another platform
next year and next year and next year I
can't wait to [__] Crush dude I keep
saying I can't wait till I die so I
don't have to can't wait to wake up
tomorrow and there's a new app that's
going to be the Nick Tik Tok it's called
dingdong and I'm like guys you got to
get on dingdong and if you're not on
[__] dingdong you're going to regret
it I [__] love it everybody thank you
for being on thank thanks thank you
we'll see you next
time
[Music]
n